sure so we're really excited uh that we
got a Federal grant for building out a
bike Skills Park at the corner of Fort
Apache and Warm Springs and so that is
moving forward we're looking looking to
start construction early next year and
get it completed by the end of 2024
early 2025 but we're really looking to
continue to build out that entire area
over there in Southwest uh part of town
and so we're partnering with the
Southern Nevada mountain bike
Association to build out more mountain
bike trails up there that will hopefully
connect up with our existing Southwest
Bridge uh Trailhead and park over there
so it's just a really exciting
opportunity to interconnect all of our
Trail systems working with the BLM on
the Red Rock Legacy trail that is also a
really exciting opportunity for safe
paved trails to get out to Red Rock
Canyon so very excited for all that's
going on out there